a few of ours Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is expected to announce the end
of a program protecting nearly eight
hundred thousand immigrants brought to
the United States legally as children
CBS News confirmed that President Trump
plans to let the program known as daca
end the Obama administration has started
daca five years ago it allows young
immigrants to obtain work permits and
avoid deportation Margaret Brennan is at
the White House when mr. Trump's
decision follows months of debate
Margaret good morning good morning well
the president is expected to gradually
wind down daca but not immediately
rescind permits or deport their
recipients instead he'll urge Congress
to craft new laws which begins yet
another public fight over whether young
undocumented immigrants should get legal
protections American activists outside
the White House Monday night urged
President Trump to uphold legal
protections for children whose parents
illegally entered the country
Luke Wang came to America at age 11
these are children who have grown up in
this country and called this home
President Trump has struggled with the
decision even praising the young
immigrants known as dreamers we love the
dreamers everybody prominent lawmakers
from both parties have encouraged mr.
Trump not to immediately end the program
but attorneys general from Texas and
nine other states threatened to sue if
the president does not agree today to
phase out the daca program
they argue that daca is the result of
presidential overreach by President
Obama who created it through executive
action in 2012 candidate Trump promised
to shut it down I will immediately
terminate President Obama's illegal
executive order on immigration but as
president mr. Trump said he was
reconsidering the daca situation is a
very very it's a very difficult thing
for me because you know I love these
kids I love kids
Maria pray Lee could be deported when
her work permit expires next February
this news has affected the lives of
800,000 people
like my cousin like myself like many
other people who who have grown up here
who are feeling really scared really
anxious Attorney General Jeff Sessions
considers a daca program
unconstitutional later today he will
explain the Trump administration's
decision and how it is going to be
enforced Gail we already know that the
attorneys general of the states of New
York and Washington are threatening to
file suit to defend daca in court a lot
of emotions have played on this thank
you very much Margaret